bonsoir non je vais en merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors pourquoi cette
décision de rejeter l'extradition
antenne surpris jusque dans le propre
camp de julian assange
oui c'était en quelque sorte une divine
surprise y compris à l'audience puisque
les avocats s'attendait à ce que la juge
décide de l'extradition et que tous les
gens qui soutenaient hausse anges dans
les jours précédents avaient préparé le
à peu le terrain à cette décision en
disant de toute façon nous ferons appel
le combat continue et puis la juge a
énuméré tous les motifs pour lesquels
les avocats avaient dit que
l'extradition ne devait pas intervenir
et les a rejetées les uns après les
autres tous les motifs juridiques ont
été écartés et à la surprise générale la
juge lundi mais il ya un motif
humanitaire pour lequel je ne ne
corrigerait pas l'extradition de julian
assange et ce motif c'est qu'il est
profondément dépressif et qu'il risque
de se suicider par conséquent il ne sera
pas extradé alors évidemment vous avez
indiqué dans votre sujet il y à une
audience mercredi prochain pour savoir
quel sera exactement son sort en
attendant que l'appel produit ses effets
est-ce qu'il sera libéré dans la logique
du juge effectivement puisqu'il est
suicidaire il devrait être soigné
probablement dans un hôpital spécialisé
probablement en effet sous surveillance
en attendant le jugement l'appel puisque
les états unis ont bien entendu fait
appel alors les etats unis ont réagi
ils se disent déçus ce soir de ce refus
julian assange peut-il bénéficier du
prochain changement de président
américain devant vous peut-être mais
fallait pas sûr parce qu'en réalité
l'administration obama dont joe biden
faisait partie puisqu'il était le vice
president avait décidé de ne pas
poursuivre finalement julian assange
notamment en raison des conséquences que
cela pourrait avoir pour les 5
en journaux internationaux qui avaient
publié une partie des documents qui
venait de wikileaks pourquoi condamner
aux 100g ne pas condamner les journaux
il y avait peut-être des raisons mais en
tout cas c'est l'argument qui avait été
retenue par l'administration obama
c'est donc l'administration trump qui a
décidé de le poursuivre et si ce n'est
pas étonnant qu'aujourd'hui
immédiatement après la la sentence du
juge londonien est bien le miz la
justice fasse appel par conséquent
monsieur trump qui est président des
états unis jusqu'au 20 janvier
continuera à réclamer la l'extradition
de julian assange aux états unis pour
qu'il soit jugé
qu'en est-il de joe biden on ne sait pas
trop parce que en effet il appartenait à
l'administration obama
il ya une dizaine d'années il avait
qualifié julian assange de dans le fond
de virtuoses du hacking de personnalités
extrêmement dangereuse probablement
probablement il laissera l'appel se
poursuivre sans retirer la demande
américaine et la justice britannique
devra donc se prononcer au bout du
compte en appel alors on a vu l'un des
partisans de julian assange dans ce
sujet dire voilà finalement ce n'est pas
une victoire pour la liberté
d'expression des journalistes c'est vrai
que julian assange est devenu un symbole
de combat pour la liberté d'informer
clairement est elle en danger
elle est toujours en danger dans divers
pays du monde
dans le cas de julian assange s'était un
peu particulier parce que je pense que
lorsqu'il a créé wikileaks en dur on est
là en 1996 lorsqu'il a créé le wikileaks
il avait tout simplement l'idée
probablement juste que le monde
numérique qui s'étendait allait
impliquer une demande croissante de
transparence de transparence de tous de
transparence de la vie privée de
transparence de la vie publique de
transparence de la politique et il a
créé cette plateforme
il s'est rendu célèbre en 2010 lorsqu'il
a diffusé une une vidéo qui montrait
deux hélicoptères militaires américains
qui par erreur apparemment tué des
civils dont deux journalistes de
l'agencé 'reuters' était évidemment
particulièrement grave et probablement
il a eu raison de diffuser cette vidéo
c'était de l'information et puis après
il a simultanément demandé à ce que tous
les toutes les personnes qui avaient des
informations puisse les mettre sur
wikileaks et il leur garantit sépare les
moyens techniques adéquates l'anonymat
absolu et donc sont arrivés les fameux
700 mille documents qui ont ensuite été
diffusées pour tout est parti ou pour
tout ou partie par les journaux qui
étaient associés à wikileaks
mais les journaux quand même pris la
précaution de faire le tri entre les
documents qu'ils risquaient de mettre en
jeu des vies humaines et les documents
qui au contraire ne faisait que rendre
transparents l'information est
effectivement dans ce domaine
et bien il y a deux limites à la liberté
totale de l'information et il faut que
cette liberté soit totale la première
limite c'est le respect de la vie privée
mais elle est le moins en moins
respectée et la deuxième c'est le secret
d'état et là aussi les états considèrent
à tort ou à raison qu'il ya certains
secteurs qui doivent être réservées que
les communications sur la sécurité
intérieure que les communications sur
les relations internationales que
les communications internes au
gouvernement doivent faire l'objet d'une
protection particulière
et il est vrai que pour les responsables
qui sont les hauts fonctionnaires d état
quel qu'il soit qu'il s'agisse des états
unis de la russie du brésil ou de
n'importe quel autre état européen est
bien la communication ne sera pas la
même si le haut fonctionnaire
responsable qui dans le cadre de ses
attributions écrit rapport c'est que ce
rapport va être public
évidemment il n'écrira pas exactement la
même chose que si je considère que ce
rapport doit rester confidentielle pour
que le gouvernement puisse juger en
toute indépendance et en toute
connaissance de cause pour le bien du
pays
donc ce débat va continuer ce débat
entre la liberté d'informer et ce débat
entre eux ce qui peut être réservé soit
dans la sphère privée soit dans la
sphère publique
merci claude blanche maison